Обурені діями Мінська європейські країни блискавично ухвалили на своєму екстреному саміті
рішення закрити авіапростір та летовища Євросоюзу для літаків з Білорусі,
а також закликали авіакомпанії не здійснювати перельотів через Білорусь.
Ми не потерпимо, аби з нами грали у російську рулетку,
коли на кону життя ні у чому не повинних мирних жителів.
23 травня білоруська влада фактично змусила до екстреної посадки літак лоукостера Ryanair,
який прямував із Греції до Литви. Привід -  бомба на борту - був явно інсценований,
аби зняти з рейсу опонента режиму Олександра Лукашенка - засновника телеграм-каналу Нехта Романа Протасевича.
Блогеру інкримінують статтю "тероризм", тож йому загрожує смертна кара.
На повітряний гоп-стоп Лукашенка відреагував і український уряд:
з 26 травня призупинено авіасполучення з Білоруссю.
Крім того, під забороною для українських авіаперевізників - білоруський авіапростір.
Які наслідки матимуть ці жорсткі кроки для України та українців?
Левову частку авіаперевезень між Білоруссю та Україною здійснювала авіакомпанія "Белавиа":
понад півсотні рейсів до низки українських міст щотижня.
За даним "Украероруху", це близько 7,5 відсотків від українського пасажирського авіатрафіку
і третє місце за кількістю польотів в український авіапростір - понад 10 тисяч за 2020 рік.
Проте закриття маршрутів через Білорусь торкнеться і багатьох українських
та іноземних авіаперевізників, а також стане проблемою для багатьох пасажирів.
Офіційних даних про річний пасажиропотік між Україною та Білоруссю ані Держприкордонслужба,
ані Украерорух чи Державна авіаційна служба не надають.
Водночас головний редактор порталу avianews Олександр Мироненко
вважає, що до Білорусі літали десятки тисяч пасажирів на тиждень:
Приблизно 10 тисяч лише які летіли до Білорусі, а далі там Білорусь або транзитом в інші країни.
Це кожного тижня. Відповідно, якщо ми беремо рейси Wizzair, Air Baltic,
які будуть облітати територію Білорусі, це так само фактично тисячі пасажирів кожного тижня.
Або можна говорити про десятки тисяч пасажирів, які можуть так чи інакше постраждати
через це протягом найближчих тижнів або місяців.
Одним з напрямків, куди літали українці з пересадкою у Білорусі,
були скандинавські країни та країни Балтії. Авіакомпанії можуть запропонувати нові прямі рейси.
Але це неминуче вплине і на ціни на квитки.
Квитки стануть дорожчими. Авіакомпанії мають витрачати більше палива
на рейси за подовженими маршрутами. Безумовно, вони мають це компенсувати
у першу чергу за рахунок пасажирів. Держави їм це компенсувати не будуть.
Особливе ж значення Мінськ як транзитний вузол мав для тих, хто з України хотів
швидко дістатися до Росії. Адже у жовтні 2015-го авіасполучення між цими двома країнами
було зупинене внаслідок запровадження взаємних санкцій.
За даними порталу anna.aero, у цей період пасажиропотік "Белавиа" на рейсах між Білоруссю та Україною
і Білоруссю та Росією збільшився на 1,4 мільйона й досяг 2,4 мільйона пасажирів,
що становило 59 відсотків від загального обсягу пасажирів, яких перевезла авіакомпанія.
Тепер до Росії найшвидше долетіти можна буде через Ригу, Варшаву або Франкфурт,
дещо довша дорога - через Стамбул або Єреван. Зрештою, в українців ще залишається
можливість приїхати до Мінська на авто, а далі вирушити літаком до Росії.
Білавіа дозволяла подорожувати до Росії найкоротшим шляхом.
З Києва до Москви це займало приблизно 3 години в один бік або тисячу кілометрів.
Якщо ми будемо брати Стамбул, то це 3 тисячі кілометрів.
Якщо Варшаву або Ригу, то це 2 тисячі км.
Відповідно шлях у порівнянні з Білавіа подовжується у 2-3 рази. Це буде і більше за часом,
і дорожче у 2 рази мінімум. Бо авіакомпанії побачать можливість заробити
і, безумовно, у цей кризовий час будуть заробляти.
Таким чином, повітряна блокада не лише ізолює Білорусь та позбавить її прибутків,
які утворилися через українсько-російську кризу. Вона також посилить повітряну блокаду,
власне, самої України, на сході та півночі. Це вдарить по тисячах українців:
бізнесменах, заробітчанах, громадянах, які хочуть відвідувати родичів у Росії.
Білоруська влада, своє чергою, надіслала Україні ноту протесту, в якій наголошує,
що через авіаційну блокаду громадяни Білорусі не зможуть повною мірою
скористатися рекреаційним потенціалом України влітку, в розпал туристичного сезону.
Скасування авіасполучення з Білоруссю, у короткостроковій перспективі,
ймовірно, ще більше погіршить економічні показники аеропортів та авіакомпаній,
які і так потерпають через пандемію.
Українські аеропорти отримують 10-20 доларів з кожного пасажира, який прямував до Білорусі.
А "Украерорух" заробив за рахунок "Белавиа" 14 мільйонів доларів протягом пандемічного 2020 року.
Керівництво аеропорту "Київ" у Жулянах вже заявило, що очікує зниження доходів аеропорту
на 10 відсотків через рішення про блокаду.
Водночас гендиректор не ставить під сумнів необхідність заборони.
Щоправда, один чинник може частково компенсувати втрачений пасажиропотік.
Якщо "Белавиа" не зможе літати до ЄС та України, більше білорусів муситимуть
вилітати у різні кінці світу з близьких до їхнього кордону аеропортів України.
Білорусам якось потрібно буде добиратися в Європу, і Україна -
один зі шляхів як добиратися в Європу.
Дуже близько розташовані до кордону Львів, Бориспіль, Жуляни, і якраз їх в основному
використовують громадяни Білорусі навіть до початку цієї кризи.
На думку глави МЗС Дмитра Кулеби, Україна виграє від ситуації, що склалася:
мовляв, нові транзитні шляхи підуть через Україну.
Своєю чергою, міністр транспорту Олександр Кубраков заявив, що Україна готова
надати максимальну підтримку державам та приватним компаніям у процесі перебудови
маршрутів через український повітряний простір.
Жорсткі рішення ЄС та України - безстрокові. Теоретично бойкот Білорусі може бути припинено,
коли Мінськ визнає свою провину в інциденті з перехопленням літака,
а також звільнить блогера Протасевича і його подругу.
Однак ніхто з експертів не вважає такий сценарій ймовірним.
Тож, швидше за все, авіапростор не буде розблоковано,
доки Олександр Лукашенко залишається при владі.